yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video i'm revealing 12 more
incredible easter eggs you might have
missed in Toy Story 4 including one
which may break the entire Pixar theory
and we also have an answer from Pixar on
whether this really is boo from monsters
Inc I'll be discussing a few spoilers so
take care if you haven't seen the movie
yet my Toy Story giveaway is still
running so subscribe hit the bell and
let me know your thoughts about Toy
Story 4 for a chance to win we're
kicking off this list with a breakdown
of the opening flashback where there's a
number of intriguing Easter eggs and Toy
Story callbacks as our C's rescue gets
underway look carefully at the cover of
the book that Molly's dolls give Bo Peep
and you'll see a little unicorn with a
rainbow mane and tail
that's a nod to rainbow unicorn one of
the actresses you worked at dream
productions and inside-out she wants
your no no sadness don't bother miss
unicorn okay no she's from out of town
and when woody is using slinky to try
and reach RC he finds he can't get near
enough until the barrel of monkeys come
to the rescue and give him the extra
length he finally needs to grab hold of
the remote-control car this is a nice
callback to the first movie where the
toys were trying to rescue bursts but
the monkeys couldn't reach far enough
it's too short
we need more monkey bones the monkeys
are working formulating another word of
this opening scene in Toy Story 4 also
fills us in on how Bo Peep ended up
separated from the other toys and the
car she's taken away and has an
incredible Pixar Easter egg on its
license plate which reads our MRF 97 if
you're scratching your head about this
cryptic combo of numbers and letters
well it's the UNIX computer command
which somebody at Pixar ran in 1997 and
which accidentally deleted the whole of
Toy Story 2 from Pixar servers the movie
was only saved because one of Pixar's
employees who was on maternity leave at
the time had taken a backup of the movie
home with her about a month earlier Toy
Story for filmmakers said they thought
it was appropriate somehow that the
license plate on the car that takes Bo
away almost killed Toy Story 2 and as
the flashback ends and the Toy Story 4
title comes on screen the camera pans up
to a blue sky filled with clouds
in a nostalgic call back to how the
first Toy Story opened with Andy holding
up Woody against the blue sky and white
cloud wallpaper in Andy's room
the orange white and black design on the
swim ring we see Bonnie wearing as she
plays with her toys is a delightful
Easter Egg to the clownfish Nemo from
the movies Finding Nemo and finding dory
when Bonnie goes to kindergarten lookout
for an easter egg on the lunchbox that
woody hides behind on the box as a
picture of reptillus maximus from the
Toy Story TV special Toy Story the time
forgot what fearsome dinosaurs are these
whole greetings I am reptillus Maximus
and it's in Bonnie's classroom where we
get the first possible appearance of boo
in Toy Story 4 ever since the trailer
for the movie dropped fans have wondered
if this is boo from Monsters Inc later
promotional material gives us a much
better look at this girl and I have to
say she does look an awful lot like boo
boo also seems to make another
appearance later in the film at the
carnival game booth where buzz ends up
with ducky and bunny one of the girls
playing the game has boos characteristic
look and many fans have also said they
think it's boo on my other toy story for
Easter eggs video the criticize have
commented that in the carnival scene boo
tries to win a prize but loses and when
she looks at the carnival worker he
doesn't care
now if boo really is in Toy Story 4 then
what does that mean for the timeline
established in the Pixar theory just in
case you're unfamiliar through a number
of Pixar theories around but the best
known one is by John Negroni who has
suggested a unified timeline for all the
Pixar films in the ground YZ Pixar
theory monsters Inc is supposed to take
place well into the future several
thousand years after the Toy Story
movies but if boo is here in Toy Story 4
how can that be
well the theory says that the monsters
in Monsters Inc are travelling back in
time when they open doors to visit
children so booth could be growing up
alongside Bonnie in getting visits from
Sally at the same time it also makes me
wonder if any of these monsters visited
Andy or Bonnie however in an attempt to
put people's boo related theories to
rest one of toy stories producers Jonas
Rivera has weighed in on the matter in
an interview with Digital Spy the
filmmaker said the following I looked at
her again
but it wasn't her maybe I should just
say it's boo but it's not
I don't think we could even use the
model of boo it's so old but we do love
boo it's just a kid that looks like her
let me know what you think in the
comments below now we need to talk more
about the Pixar theory as there's an
easter egg that Toy Story Force director
Josh coolly deliberately added to the
movie in reference to it in an interview
with Joe Blow Cooley said that in the
scene were Bonnie and her family are at
the RV park her mom is sitting outside
reading a book titled beyond infinity
debunking theories of a shared universe
cool II didn't say whether he was just
poking fun at the Pixar theory with this
Easter Egg or was purposely trying to
debunk it however it is interesting
that's in the final curse of Toy Story 4
the director decided to change the angle
of the shot so that the title of the
book was obscured though he says that he
did it because it was too distracting
for the audience so whether all the
Easter eggs we'd love to talk about in
Pixar movies actually add up to a fully
connected shared universe is still up
for debate and in some ways Toy Story 4
does confirm some aspects of the Pixar
theory even if it raises other questions
one part of the theory is that toys come
to life thanks to the energy they feed
off children's emotions and when Toy
Story 4 introduces for ki he's really
confused about why he's alive why am i
alive you're Bonnie's toy you are going
to help create happy memories that will
last for the rest of her life on one
hand the fact that Bonnie created an
unloved fork he seems to confirm the
Pixar theory idea was a toy comes to
life from the energy they receive from a
child's emotions
but there's still a moment in the mid
credit scene where four commits a new
cutlery soulmate who when she asks how
am i alive
for key replies I don't know in fact Toy
Story for filmmakers deliberately added
this scene with four key in order to
have what they've called a
get-out-of-jail-free card in an
interview with Digital Spy Josh coolly
said part of me doesn't want to try and
answer all the magic of white toys are
alive in four keys case bonny has given
him a new purpose but that's not always
the case where toys haven't had kids and
are still alive there are dozens more
Easter eggs in Toy Story 4 which you
might have missed
including a113 the Pizza Planet truck
and the luxo ball all of which are
hidden in the antique store and the
carnival
you should check those out Plus over 50
more Easter eggs in my other Toy Story 4
video click the screen to watch it or
check the link in the video description
below so how do you think Toy Story 4
fits in with the Pixar theory share your
thoughts in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe to enter my toy story
giveaway and do you think that was
actually boo in the movie I've added a
poll where you can vote just tap in the
top of this video and after you've cast
your vote you'll be able to see the
results if you enjoyed this do hit that
thumbs up button and tap left my other
toy story for Easter eggs video or tap
right for some more Pixar or other
videos you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers